To work with them is honestly the highlight of my
career me and tobey arrived and
all of their arms were just open
i had butterflies with tobey and
andrew hoping they would sign up
how they became super villains it's just
so funny i fell into a super collider
Welcome back everyone it is pizza time o'clock
sony is dropping the spider-man no way home
blu-ray in april and they released this
special features trailer with a bunch of
tobey maguire andrew garfield deleted scenes
just to get everyone hyped up there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs and a bunch a bunch of
deleted scenes of all this stuff so we'll
break it all down we already know what
all the bonus features are going to be
and which scenes got deleted that they're
putting back on because there were a ton
of deleted scenes that probably will not
make the blu-ray that we found out about
lotta tobey maguire andrew garfield and matt
murdock daredevil as you can see obviously they
put a little bit of matt burdock daredevil in here
they're finally using the three spideys to promote
the movie wondered how long they were going to
wait on that if you're brand new to the channel i
am doing a giveaway for the blu-rays all you have
to do to enter is just be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the movie on the video
i don't think we need a spoiler warning for the
movie because sony is using everything from the
movie to actually promote it so i think we're way
past that surprisingly i've still seen a couple
comments on videos the last couple of days people
that have still not seen spider-man no way home
somehow they managed to not see it but this is the
full list of bonus features that are going to be
on the blu-ray now i know you're like pausing the
video zoom enhance zoom enhance to see the really
important stuff but i'll draw your eye here zoom
in enhance to this part the three spidey's hangout
scene happy's very good lawyer scene in the
extended interrogation scene that's where most of
like the really really cool deleted scene stuff is
he is chomping at the oh my god i just can't and
it's been killing me because of the whole secrecy
thing because i want to go around and go hey yeah
there you go now there's a lot of featurettes on
this too where tobey maguire andrew garfield will
be talking about coming back all the sinister six
villains green goblin doctor octopus jamie foxx's
electro and just everyone geeking out on each
other's versions of spider-man and their movies
because everybody that was part of this movie
is such a huge fan of each other's spider-man
franchises but one of my favorite things from
this new trailer is that they revealed that they
actually did the three-way spider-man pointing
meme and andrew garfield actually revealed that he
was the person that came up with that idea he said
that one day he just came to set and just did it
was like just go with it dudes just go with it you
can actually see that tom holland tripped while
they were trying to do this somehow he tripped
while they were just pointing at each other and
the really cool thing about tobey maguire andrew
garfield coming back is that kevin feige said that
that was the idea really early on now it took a
little while to get things going but despite what
a lot of news sites were saying a couple years ago
tobey maguire and andrew garfield said that they
were on board almost immediately from the jump
the minute that marvel called them revisiting
you know what what was part of my history and
and getting a chance to like come together and a
way to revisit and just just to get to get back
into that and i don't want to say like close the
chapter but revisit and have certain resolutions
um and and just join in this like loving creative
spirit the only questions that most of them
had when they were signing on were what was the
script going to be what were the scenes actually
going to look like but it was around december
2019 when they had signed on to the movie so
more than two years ago at this point i can't
remember exactly when i posted my first tobey
maguire andrew garfield video but for the longest
time during 2020 there were just rumors that tobey
maguire was waiting to sign onto the film turns
out nope turns out he signed on december 2019 just
like andrew garfield as for the actual deleted
scenes the three spidey's hangout scene is just a
much longer alternate version of them all just
hanging out literally as the title implies they
overshot everything so there's just a lot of
outtakes of them just doing all their different
scenes together the writers said the first time
they actually meet each other in the movie all
three of them meet on screen on the top of midtown
high they had to rewrite that scene about 10
different times just to get it right just because
they wanted to nail the emotionality of what was
going on in this scene for tom holland's peter
parker and not make it feel too comedic or over
the top because it would have been really easy to
do that tobey maguire actually said that that was
his big concern when he was signing onto the film
too is that it wouldn't just be like a hello it's
pizza time and then he'd leave it rides up in
the crotch a little bit too making tobey maguire
andrew garfield's versions of spider-man integral
to the actual plot of the film the happy's very
good lawyer deleted scene is just part of the matt
murdock daredevil extended scenes it's meant to
take place after the actual daredevil scene that
we got in the movie or the matt murdock scene
however you want to think about it because he
acts as daredevil but he's not wearing the costume
he's really there to help peter parker and
the others as matt murdock lawyer by day
which is a little wink at his daredevil abilities
catching that brick john favreau actually revealed
what was going on in the deleted scene version
of this though if you don't remember a billion
years ago john favreau played a version of foggy
nelson in the ben affleck daredevil movie listen
this eyewitnesses say that quesada was singled out
by the demonic vigilante known as the daredevil
i don't know why you read that trash i've been
hearing stories about this guy for years there's
gonna be something to it what like the alligators
and the sewers there are alligators in the sewers
don't write my ass about the alligators i got a
friend in sanitation okay in the theatrical cut
matt murdock tells happy you need to find a really
good lawyer and that's kind of what they end on
but in the deleted scene they just go on and make
more references to the ben affleck daredevil movie
in the daredevil netflix series john favreau said
that he has some dialogue where he talks about
having a foggy memory and that's meant to be a
reference to that ben affleck daredevil movie
they also have a deleted scene with an extended
version of the interrogation scene when damage
control was just laying into them about what was
going on with mysterio's drones i don't know if
it actually made the blu-ray but during a version
of that supposedly matt murdock shows up at the
end of the interrogation to help peter parker
then they go back to aunt may's apartment and he
explains to them what the situation is the version
that we saw in theaters some of the deleted scenes
that did not make the blu-ray just looking at
the titles of some of these are the alternate
ending that they did for tobey maguire and andrew
garfield's characters the writers also explained
that they plotted out endings for each of their
characters that were a little bit different
so in the theatrical cut the spell sends them back
to their original universes there's been a lot of
argument as to whether or not they would remember
tom holland's peter parker they would definitely
remember the multiverse and working with another
version of spider-man but because dr strange's
spell was meant to erase everyone's memory of
peter parker there's now a lot of question as to
how they're going to handle that during spider-man
4 when they get to that next movie especially when
tobey maguire andrew garfield come back in other
future spider-man movies because separately both
of them did say that they would be coming back
eventually but what was going to happen is that
they were going to actually do legit post credit
scenes for topee maguire and andrew garfield
and during those they were just going to show you
in their own universes what was going on with them
next in their continuing storyline into the future
like a lot of people have been calling for them to
make amazing spider-man 3 now because andrew
garfield was so amazing during the movie like
how can you not do amazing spider-man 3 now his
whole arc in the film was sort of getting over
gwen stacy's death more fully embracing the
role of friendly neighborhood spider-man that
gwen stacy wanted him to be as he said which is
kind of what's happening to tom holland's peter
parker in the mcu right now he's becoming the more
friendly neighborhood spider-man version of the
character i've already talked about all the andrew
garfield morbius easter eggs during the amazing
spider-man 2 at that time sony was also setting
up a bunch of other spin-offs there were a bunch
of morbius easter eggs venom easter eggs they
were going to do versions of all those characters
in andrew garfield's universe of movies so now
that they bridged all the different movies using
the multiverse it's a lot easier to bring those
actors back tobey maguire andrew garfield for some
of the other extended current sony films right
now there's just a lot more opportunities where
they could take andrew garfield spider-man in the
future of all these movies as for tobey maguire he
has his own version of a movie that almost was but
it was spider-man 4 in his case we actually know a
lot about what the plot of that movie was going to
be vulture was going to be the main villain what
would have happened when he went back because they
would have just teased more about what's going
him he didn't say that he had a daughter with her
yet but they could do the mayday parker character
then gets his spider-man powers and becomes
a version of spider-man herself in the future
tobey maguire also said that when he signed on for
the film he specifically asked the writers of the
movie not to get in too deep as to what happened
to his character after the events of spider-man
3. like don't give away all that spider-man 4
story or like you know what happened in between
those movies mostly now because they have the
opportunity to tell that in other future sony
spider-man films like don't give away the milk for
free because then people won't buy the cow people
won't buy those movie tickets if they already know
what the story is i've already done a bunch of
other deleted scenes videos for the movie so i'll
link some of those at the end of this especially
the venom deleted scenes i believe they're
releasing the movie on digital next week so once
they do that i will do like a much longer version
of these deleted scenes videos with the actual
scenes themselves and i will do a couple rounds of
this giveaway in my next couple of marvel videos
everyone click here to learn about all those
venom deleted scenes in spider-man no way home and
alternate post credit scene and click here for my
full doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!